it's the hottest day ever recorded in
the uk
and in london alone the fire brigade is
dealing with more than 1 000 incidents
here's how the day unfolded in the worst
hit community in wenington east london
the fire starts at around 1 pm
this video shows resident alfie stock
trying to put out the early stages of
the fire with a garden hose he lives
here at 22 the green he says the fire
started in a compost pile at the house
next door that was empty at the time the
exact cause of the fire is still being
investigated
the london fire brigade received the
first call alerting them to the incident
at 106 pm they arrive seven minutes
later the fire started less than a
hundred meters from wennington fire
station the crews based there were five
miles away in upminster attending
another fire
at 204 pm the sky news helicopter is
heading towards the essex coastline and
spots the fire
alfie stock's house here at number 22
and next door are already gutted and the
fire has spread to number 20.
the wind direction appears to be playing
a big part in how the fire spreads
further it's moving north west pushing
the fire towards more houses
it's been an hour since the fire started
and it's travelled more than 200 metres
west to these gardens ten minutes later
at 2 28 it's reached this house and
completely engulfed the large
outbuilding
in the fields to the south landowners
are trying to stop the spread by
creating a channel in the field using a
tractor and are moving water containers
in to help
but it doesn't work two hours later we
can see the landowners fail to stop the
spread and it's continued to move south
across the fields
and in the village the fire has now
moved 400 meters west five houses on
wellington road in our lights and it's
moving fast nine minutes later a further
two houses have caught fire
in video film the next morning the
grounds of the church are charred but
the building itself remains intact
in total we counted 17 houses severely
damaged plus a number of other buildings
including garages and stables
it took the fire brigade eight hours to
get it under control
the 19th of july 2022 made history for
the wrong reasons the hottest day since
records began the busiest day for the
london fire brigade since world war ii
across the country fire services
declared 14 major incidents and we are
told climate change means this will not
be a one-off
adam parker sky news